if you're a fan of the Resident Evil  movies I have some news that might pique  your interest Paul WS Anderson the man  behind the zombie movies is taking on  another Capcom property deadline reports  that he set his sights on Monster Hunter  and is shopping it around two movie  studios right now speaking about the  game series Anderson said what I love  about Monster Hunter is the incredibly  beautiful immersive world they've  created it's on the level of like a Star  Wars movie in terms of world creation  there are no real central characters so  it's a bit like when we first approached  Resident Evil I think this is a perfect  IP for us to do exactly that same thing  again  Anderson teased that he has quote about  two movies planned for monster hunter  with a budget similar to Resident Evil's  there's no word on a release date or  casting right now but Anderson will  presumably be the director to keep up  with all the latest monster hunter news  you're already in the right place